In today's video,
we're showing you a simple recipe
to make your own air dry clay.
It only has a couple of ingredients.
You can easily change the colors
using food coloring,
and you can sand it and
paint it beautifully.
[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
[Music]
To get started, of course,
we'll need a bag of baking soda,
and some corn starch.
Here's the basic idea.
You cook baking soda, cornstarch,
and water on the stove for a few minutes,
and it turns into a soft clay.
That clay can be dyed with food coloring,
and shaped into whatever you want.
Let it sit out for a couple days,
and it will dry completely hard.
Let's start out with 1/2
of a cup of corn starch.
[Music]
After half a cup of corn starch,
we need one full cup of baking soda.
[Music]
Now, to finish this off,
we need 3/4 cups of cold water.
[Music]
Now, without putting it on the stove yet,
stir this all together until it's
one smooth consistency.
I think we've probably
all seen what happens
when we mix water with cornstarch,
and so it's going to be
a little lumpy at first.
[Music]
After your mixture is all smooth,
it's time to throw it on the
stove at medium heat.
They ask you how you are,
you just have to say that you're fine,
and you're not really fine.
[Music]
After a few minutes of stirring,
your mixture will get to something that
looks almost completely indistinguishable
from mashed potatoes.
Transfer it to a heat safe surface
to let it cool down.
While you're letting it cool down,
cover it with a wet paper towel.
This clay dries out,
and that makes it hard and unworkable,
and you don't want it to dry out
before you get a chance to sculpt it.
After our clay has cooled off,
we now have something that
can easily be sculpted,
molded, shaped and colored.
This really does look a lot
like mashed potatoes.
It doesn't smell like mashed
potatoes of course.
Mostly, it smells like the corn starch.
It doesn't have as much of
the baking soda smell.
I think corn starts just has
a stronger smell in general.
[Music]
It's non-toxic.
It's not going to do anything to you.
It's just baking soda and cornstarch,
but it's bad.
Let's try adding a little bit of
color to some of our clay.
Just one drop of yellow.
[Music]
There we go.
I'm really just going to run
with that mashed potatoes look,
and this little pad of butter.
[Music]
Gently mixing a couple of colors together
can give you a cool marbled effect.
If you're trying to make larger
pieces out of clay,
it can crack a little bit as
it dries if it's too thick.
So, I recommend using
some foil as a base shape,
and then, sculpting the clay around that.
[Music]
Let's see if we can't use this clay
to try and make a casting.
[Music]
It's been a few days and our baking soda
cornstarch clay has had time to dry.
Let's see how things turned out.
[Music]
Our Lego brick molded fairly well,
but it did curve a little
bit as it was curing,
so, I'm not sure if we'd be able to get
that to clip onto a real Lego brick or not.
Let's give it a test.
That's a, slightly attached right there.
The curve I think is going to make it
have a harder time
attaching to an entire brick.
This clay does shrink a
tiny bit as it dries,
so it's not quite the same
shape as it was before.
[Music]
It It has some grip though.
It's kind of like knockoff brand Lego,
just not as good.
Doesn't fit quite as well.
See how R2D2 is doing.
[Music]
Ooh! R2D2 turned out great.
This silicone mold is meant for
making R2D2 shaped ice cubes.
We've made a nice little
plastic-like figure instead.
Picked up some really
good details in there as well.
Again, these are molds
designed for making ice cubes.
These ones are of course shaped
like little Lego figures,
and again, did a good job getting the details.
It's a, it's a pretty good casting right there.
Tool holder for my individual drill bits.
[Music]
Let's try sanding this clay,
and see how well that works.
[Music]
It sands really nicely.
Very smooth grain,
takes it down pretty fast.
[Music]
That gets pretty nice and smooth.
So, sandpaper does
a very good job with this.
Now, this piece,
I actually just made to
do a strength test.
So, I'm going to see how
easily it can break this.
[Music]
It's harder than a cookie.
I would say that
it's decently hard to snap.
Something like this would,
I'd say you can count on
that to be durable,
unless you're deliberately
trying to break it,
even dropping it a little bit,
don't really have to worry
too much about it.
It's not super fragile.
One final test,
let's see how well this stuff takes paint.
We're going to hit with
layer of spray paint,
and see if it takes the color nicely.
[Music]
I would say that the paint
worked pretty well.
I only did a couple of layers of it,
and it's nice and covered.
It really does a good job of going on top
of the color of clay you already have.
If it's already starting with white,
I'm sure you can get even better
coverage than if you're trying to
go over a contrasting color.
Baking soda, cornstarch, and water,
It's easy to make.
Only takes a few minutes.
You can add colors with food coloring.
You can add colors with paint.
It's pretty durable.
It sands really well.
You can make decorative pieces.
You can make useful pieces.
This stuff is pretty neat all around.
Guys, the fun doesn't have to end.
That box up at the top will transport
you directly to our last video,
and you should go check that out.
The box at the bottom will show you what
YouTube thinks you need to be watching next,
and this bomb in the middle
will subscribe to the channel,
so you never miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.